STEREN GIANNINI: Hello, hello.
Welcome.
MYLES BORINS: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
MYLES BORINS: It's
been a long day.
It's been a long three days.
And I know Steren
and myself really
appreciate all of you
sticking around and coming
to our session.
So just one more time,
thank you everyone.
STEREN GIANNINI: It's
good to have you with us.
This is Myles, Myles Borins.
Myles is a developer
advocate on Google Cloud
and we've been working
together for the last year.
He also happens to be the
director of the Node.js
Technical Steering Committee.
[APPLAUSE]
And of course he's a
long time Node.js lover.
I think the first
time you used Node.js
was for an Earth installation?
Something like that.
Nice.
MYLES BORINS: So this is Steren.
Steren is a product manager
for Google Cloud Platform
on the serverless team.
And we've been working
really closely on new Node.js
technologies.
Previously was involved in the
Stackdriver Error Reporting
product.
And you used Node in
production in 2011?
Was that like 04 or 06?
STEREN GIANNINI: 06 I think.
MYLES BORINS: 06.
Did anyone start with
Node 06 in the audience?
Right on.
That was buggy.
I think that's like right when
they introduced [? Util. ?]
But fun fact about Steren.
His wedding invitation was
actually written in JavaScript
and it's still online.
And that means your wedding
invitation will never break.
STEREN GIANNINI: Never.
The web.
All right.
So who can name
these French pastry?
So it's called a
millefeuille, literally
translating to thousand layers.
So it's basically a cake made
of many, many, many layers.
So one of my
teachers used to say
in French [SPEAKING FRENCH] Sort
of translating, every problem
is millefeuille
of simple things.
So you should understand every
problem can be broken down
into many simple things.
And I think this is also
true for software, for code,
but also for software
architectures.
If you break down your big
app into simple things,
it will be simpler.
Until you break them
down into Microservices.
So that brings us
to Microservices.
Why Microservices?
Well, maybe your app
has grown too big.
Maybe it's actually hard
to understand, deadlocked,
maintain, manage.
This is why Microservices
can be a solution.
You break up the monolith.
You decouple those
Microservices.
You make them simpler to
understand and maintain.
And potentially
each service will
be written in a
different language,
owned by a different team,
and deployed independently.
As a consequence, they
will scale independently
if you've decoupled them.
The scaling is independent, too.
And by making them
more fine-grained,
that will result in a better
utilization of your resources.
That will result in
a lower bill for you.
And lastly, Microservices
pair great with Node.js
due to the asychronous
nature of Node.js.
So Microservices
break up the monolith,
scale independently, and
pair great with Node.js.
But what is Node.js?
MYLES BORINS: So I
was given this slide.
Node.js.
JavaScript, how many
people like JavaScript?
Sweet.
So I don't if any
of you have ever
seen this little emoji thing
before, the rocket turtle.
That was the Node.js logo.
It was kind of like a joke.
Substack drew this
turtle on a rocket ship
because JavaScript was not
supposed to be a fast language.
It was pretty amazing
how fast, both as a
runtime, but also for iteration.
Node is one of those things
that just you have an idea
and you can get it
done in like 10 or 15
minutes because someone's
already written the module.
You just need to find it.
At its base, Node is
a JavaScript runtime.
We take the V8
virtual machine that
comes in the Chrome
browser, we wrap it
with libuv, which is an
underlying architecture
wrapping all the system calls.
And that kind of abstracts
all the different platforms
and allows developers to
just write JavaScript and be
able to do compute,
write servers,
and all those different things.
It allows you to leverage
your front end skills.
It's event driven.
What that means is that
compute is driven by events.
Something computes
when something happens.
That can be an HTTP request.
That can be some sort of
message coming over a socket.
It can be user input
with a keyboard.
It can be some sensor if
you're working with IoT.
Any form of I/O.
So anytime there's
input, some sort
of compute runs.
The [? adventure ?]
of an architecture
plays really great with async
non-blocking I/O. Multiple
things can run in parallel
without blocking each other.
When I make some sort of
request over a socket,
I'm able to suspend, let
other things execute,
and resume when I'm done
without requiring the developer
to program any of this.
It just happens.
Many events execute without
blocking each other.
And this ends up being
really great for web servers
because it means
multiple people can
connect to the same
process at the same time
and it just works.
You don't have to
worry about mutex.
worry about timing.
You just worry about
handling the events.
So to sum that up, Node.js
is JavaScript runtime
that's event driven with
async non-blocking I/O.
STEREN GIANNINI:
And the last term
that we need to define
from the title of this talk
is serverless.
So who here is using
a serverless product?
So we should agree that there
are a lot of definitions
for serverless.
I'm going to highlight here
the key characteristics
that we use along this talk.
The first one that, to me,
is the main characteristic
is that you pay
for what you use.
So it's a billing model.
If you don't use
it, you don't pay,
and then the bill is
proportional to your usage.
Of course you don't need
to provision in advance
and your resource, all of
this, is done on demand.
So why are we able to
achieve that billing model?
Because of an operational model.
So a serverless product
will scale with usage
without having to
worry about it.
It grows with you from a
single developer to a company
with thousands of developers.
It follows your usage.
And why can it scale?
Because of a programming model.
The cloud providers
takes care of the rest.
You focus on your code.
That means that no
infrastructure management,
no VM management.
Everything is
abstracted from you.
So you focus on your code.
That also means that you focus
on delivering business value
and value to your users.
So to recap, serverless,
pay for what you use,
it scales and allows
you to focus on code.
These are the principles we
have to use along that talk
and you will see it's not
actually not only for compute.
MYLES BORINS: So
Google Cloud has
a number of different
serverless offerings.
We have Cloud Functions.
How many people here have been
using Node in Cloud Functions
so far?
Cool.
We've got App Engine
Standard, we've
got Data Store, Cloud storage,
BigQuery Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
ML Engine, the Firebase
suite, as well as AppScripts.
And all of these
different products,
what defines them as serverless
and makes them all serverless
is the fact that you
don't have to manage them.
We will scale them for you.
We will manage them for you.
You can utilize them
as much as you need it.
STEREN GIANNINI:
And today, we are
very proud to share with you the
preview of Node.js on the App
Engine standard environment.
[APPLAUSE]
STEREN GIANNINI: Thank you.
So yes, we are adding a new
language to App Engine's
standard, Node.js.
We will release
it in a few weeks.
So let's see a small demo of
Node.js on App Engine standard.
Myles is going to tell
you more about it.
MYLES BORINS: So this
package json file
is outlining a hello
world application.
We have a single start script
that calls node on server.js.
Which fun little fact, if you
don't define the start script
and you just run npm
start, that's actually
the default command
it will just do,
which can be really
confusing if you're not
expecting it to do that.
And it has a single
dependency, which is Express.
Here's our Express app.
We're making an
app using Express.
We have a single route.
And we celebrate Node.js
on App Engine standard.
We listen on an environment
variable for the port
or fall back to 80-84
local development.
And there's one more
thing that we'll
need to get this onto
App Engine standard.
It's just a tiny bit of YAML.
This one line of YAML
runtime Node.js 8
is the only extra
thing that you need
to add to the majority
of Node.js apps.
And it will work as soon as
you run a single command.
And that command is
gcloud app deploy.
So Steren has something
loaded up on his computer.
So we're going to switch
over to it right now.
And your going to see
Steren's in the Cloud Shell.
He's got that app that
we were just showing you.
And he's going to
type in that command
that I just mentioned,
gcloud app deploy.
So this is how you
know it's a real demo.
But we haven't actually deployed
yet, we're ready to deploy now.
STEREN GIANNINI: Ready to go?
MYLES BORINS: You're ready?
STEREN GIANNINI: Let's do it.
MYLES BORINS: So we're
starting to deploy.
And in the time it
takes to deploy,
I'm going to try to list all
the things I like about it.
So it's an idiomatic
node runtime environment.
So that means we're using the
exact version of Node that
gets published by Node.js.
There's no special runtimes,
there are no special APIs,
it's the same app you
can run in other places.
It scales to zero.
So when you're not using it,
you're not paying for it.
It's a managed runtime.
So that means
everything but your code
and the node modules that you're
using will get updated by us.
If there is a security fix
that needs to land into Node
or open SSL-- and
trust me, there
are-- we're going to
patch that for you
without you or your users
really ever noticing.
Oh, wow.
I couldn't even get to it.
It's already deployed.
You also get npm
install in the Cloud.
So that also did npm install.
You get hybrid monitoring for
free and free and free HTTPS.
Wow, that was fast.
If we can go, we
can see the service.
Right now it's already running.
STEREN GIANNINI: Sorry.
MYLES BORINS: The
bar was hiding it.
So there you go.
This service has been deployed.
We're already running it.
And this is, in my opinion, it's
a really great user experience.
Being able to deploy, have it
up in the Cloud so quickly,
and be able to share that
with people to take a look.
So now that we're
done with the demo,
we're going to talk
a little bit more.
STEREN GIANNINI: So this
was Node.js on App Engine
standard environment.
It is idiomatic,
which means that you
can use any module from the
npm registry that you want.
There is no API or
language restriction.
As you've seen, it deploys
fast and scales instantly.
And as Myles said, it is secure.
So you get one-click HTTPS
for your custom domains,
and [INAUDIBLE] updates.
So I will now do a deep
dive into three updates
pieces of our infrastructure.
The first one that is
what we call internally
faster than light builds.
So what's that?
When you type gcloud
app deploy, we
will first only upload the
files that have actually
changed since last time.
This is an optimization
for the upload process.
The faster than light
build arrives after.
So what we do is we look
at your package.json
and package-lock.json to install
your dependencies in the Cloud.
So we do npm install
for you in the cloud.
Good.
So this is what we defined
as the speed of light.
But actually, if we notice
that your package.json
and your dependencies
haven't changed, well,
what we are going to
do is just give you
what we just gave you before
if you do a new deployment.
So we use our caching system
to give user cache to modules.
And that's how we can
go faster than light.
This was the first piece
of data infrastructure
for this new runtime.
The second one is a new
runtime environment.
So let's hear a bit of
the technical stack.
So first, you gave us your code
when you did gcloud app deploy.
So this is your
application code.
As I said, we installed
the Node modules for you.
So including the native modules,
they can be any modules.
Good.
Under that, of course,
there is Node.js.
And here, this is an
off-the-shelf Node.js.
There's no special
customization here.
Node is relying on
the OS packages.
And for example, you might have
heard about Headless Chrome.
And yes, all of the packages
needed to run Headless Chrome
are present in the
App Engine image.
And that lives on top of a
regular OS, which is Ubuntu.
The last three pieces--
Node, OS packages, and Ubuntu--
are automatically
updated without you
having to worry about it.
So you'll automatically
update your Node.js version,
the minor and patch
version of the Node.js.
The OS package and the OS is
also automatically updated.
All of that lives in
a secured sandbox.
And this is a new
sandbox technology
that we are introducing
with this new runtime.
Under the hood, the sandbox
is based on G Vysor.
So G Vysor is a
content runtime sandbox
that we open sourced last week.
Check it out.
This is our new
runtime environment.
And the last piece
of infrastructure
I would like to highlight
is automatic scaling.
So what is automatic scaling?
Let's take an example.
So App Engine constantly
monitors the instance capacity
and traffic, your application
capacity and traffic.
And it ensures that the
appropriate number of instances
are available to run
your application.
So what does that mean?
Let's take an example.
So as I said, if there
is no request arriving
to your application, there
is no instance scheduled.
And when I say instance,
it's not a VM instance,
it's an abstract that
we named instance.
OK, now some traffic
arrives to your application.
Well, we will scale up as
fast as possible one instance.
Here I'm going to
pause for a second.
I want to highlight
one concept that is
very important for developers.
The very first of
these requests really
hits what we call a cold start.
That means that this request
will actually hit the instance
while it is starting up.
And this usually results in
a higher latency than usual.
Of course we try to not
retry, but we do boot up
the instance very, very fast.
But you also have a
responsibility here.
You have to ensure that your
start command is fast too.
So in the start script of
your package [INAUDIBLE],,
make sure to not do
things like build
or a lot of initialization.
Do the minimum required
to start your application,
because this will have an
impact on the cold start
of your application.
OK, so here as I said,
the very first request
will hit this cold start.
But the next ones,
everything is fine.
But then your traffic will
start to increase a little bit.
And here, before this first
instance arrives at capacity,
we will anticipate that
you need a second one.
And we will actually
schedule a second one.
So that when you actually
need it, it's there.
Doesn't need to scale more.
And now let's imagine your app
is featured on a popular blog
post and you have a
huge spike of traffic.
Well, don't worry.
App Engine scales very fast.
So it would be to scale up
instances as much as needed.
You control, you can tell us a
maximum of number of instances
if that matters to you.
And of course, when
things go down,
well we will ramp down the
number of instances to zero.
So that's what we call
automatic scaling.
You did not have to do
anything to get this behavior.
But this is not new at all.
App Engine has been doing that
for 10 years, 10 years now.
What is new is that actually we
updated our automatic scaling
algorithm.
So the updates include
it is more predictable.
As a developer, you will better
understand how it behaves.
When you look at
your instance chart,
you will better understand it.
Second, it actually improves
the instance utilization
and performance.
So we measured a reduction
of 30% of those cold starts.
So that means that the
detail, the latency
of all of our apps across all
of App Engine has went down.
And also better utilization
means lower bills
for everybody using App Engine.
And this was released
in the last months.
The third point are
new settings that we
are introducing to better
control this automatic scaling
algorithms.
Those new settings
help you balance
between cost and performance.
Also, as I said, help you
cap the number of instances
so that you can cap your bill
but also the number of database
connections, for example.
So this was three pieces of
infrastructure we updated.
Up to you, Myles.
MYLES BORINS: So
we built a product
with Node.js comprised
of Microservices
to share with you today.
And Steren's going to demo it
on the machine for us right now.
STEREN GIANNINI: All
right, so go for it.
MYLES BORINS: So we
created a web page watcher.
And we're able to put an
address into the submission bar
and it will start watching it.
And at five-minute
increments, it's
going to use Headless
Chrome to take a screen
capture of the website.
And it's going to compare
it to other screen captures.
And it's going to only
take screen captures
when there's actually been
a difference in the page.
This website allows
you to set any number
of different websites to watch.
And this has been a lot of fun
to use on the Google website
to see the changes
to the Google header.
You could use it to watch
your own site to make sure
that things aren't going down
if you have a personal page that
isn't changing a lot.
But it was a way for us to
experiment with breaking things
into different services,
and put together
a really great example.
So Steren, did you have anything
you wanted to add to that?
STEREN GIANNINI: I want
to tell you how it's done.
MYLES BORINS: That sounds great.
STEREN GIANNINI: Let's
get back to the slides.
So this is our product.
This is our application
the website watcher.
How did we build it?
Well, every five
minutes there is
a cron job that's we trigger
of a first Microservices.
This Microservice is
called Task Scheduler.
The job of this Microservice is
to ask our database for a list
of web pages to screenshot.
When it receives this list,
it will actually [? enqueue ?]
into a Pub/Sub topic a message
for each page to screenshot.
This is the first Microservice.
Then Pub/Sub will dispatch,
will push to a second
Microservice, the web pages.
And the job of
this Microservice,
is it has one job, is
to take screenshots.
So as I said previously,
this is using
Headless Chrome under
the hood, [INAUDIBLE]
to take the screenshots.
So it opens a web page,
takes a screenshot,
saves it into Google
Cloud Storage.
That's its only job.
Now a new file arrives
into Cloud Storage.
This will send an event that
will trigger a Google Cloud
function that will compare
this new screenshot
with the last known reference
screenshot for that web page.
We call it image diff because
the job of that function
is to compare two images.
And if there is a difference
between the images,
it will store the new image into
a new folder in Google Cloud
Storage.
So this is how we
continuously get
the updates of all of the web
pages that we want to track.
OK now, a user arrives
onto a website.
So an HTP request arrives
onto our web Frontend,
another Microcservice, that
will query our database asking
for a list of web pages.
You've seen that list.
And when I see the detail
of one of those web pages,
we actually display
the screenshots.
So it also queries
Cloud Storage.
So that's how we
build our products.
Four custom Microservices all
communicating with each other.
And now, Myles is going to
tell you more about the code.
MYLES BORINS: So the first
Microservice that we're showing
is our screenshot server.
You're going to notice
we're using async functions
because App Engine
standard comes
with Node 8 out of the box.
We're going to start a browser
session by awaiting Puppeteer
to launch.
We're going to then await a new
page from the browser object.
We're going to await
surfing to that URL.
We'll await setting the viewport
to the size of the image
that we want to take.
And then we'll await a
screenshot in the image buffer.
We then await
closing the browser.
And then we return
the image buffer.
We're doing a lot of
asynchronous work in here
that is going to allow us to
use the same service to pull
lots of different images
at the exact same time
without blocking.
We're able to do it in
a single linear fashion
without having to manage
a whole bunch of callbacks
or any sorts of promises.
Although under the
hood, there's lots
of different promises going on.
Now, this is deployed
using App Engine standard.
And there were some
other talks going
on this week about
Headless Chrome.
And you can find those
if you go and check
the I/O webpage later.
So this is the part
of the service that
actually saves to a bucket.
Similarly we're
using Async/Await
to be able to do this
in a linear fashion.
But we go to the
bucket, we rename
the images to be
based on a time stamp,
and we save it, and await that
information, and then log it.
And because all of the Node.js
client libraries support
promises, you're going to be
able to use our various client
libraries to talk to all
of our various servers
using Async/Await
right out of the box.
And then the last
thing that we wanted
to show you was the image
diff from our Cloud Function
that's doing the image diff.
Every time a new file gets
added to a Cloud Storage bucket,
this function's
automatically called.
And what we wanted to
just show is how quickly
from the event that the
function is executed with
we can grab the file
and the context at which
of that file inside
of Cloud Storage.
So we don't even need
to write any logic
to tie the two together.
We just use one
service to save it,
and this new
service just reacts.
And one thing that's
really great about all
these different services
is that out of the box,
if you start logging,
Stackdriver's
going to grab all of
those logs and you're
going to be able to use
Stackdriver logging to look
at all the logs of
what's going on.
And I don't know about you, but
I never write a service right
at the first sign.
I write it locally, and then it
works differently in the cloud.
Being able to just log and have
it working is really awesome.
For the demo that
we put together,
you'll see online
later we used Bunyan
and have a pretty
robust logging system
that you'll be able
to take a look at.
STEREN GIANNINI: So let's
look at the Cloud Console
to see those Microservices
in the console.
So as I said, we do have
three App Engine services.
So you will see them on
the App Engine dashboard.
So opening my services-- or
we have four because I just
deployed one earlier with you.
So defaults,
screenshot, task editor.
We have one cloud function.
So if I open it,
it will display here.
Image diff, as you
see, the trigger
is a Cloud Storage
bucket trigger.
Now, as Myles said, out of
the box all of your logs
are going to be collected
into Stackdriver logging.
So here, let me filter
out some of those logs
and only show the application
logs that are here.
So these are the logs for our
app across all of our services.
So as you see, we see
we loaded the website.
We save screenshots
so all of this
gets logged, and with
a different severity.
Here we had an
error, apparently.
And the last thing
I wanted to show
is that when your logs
go to Stackdriver,
they are going to be
collected and grouped together
by Stackdriver Error Reporting.
So what you see here is
a list of error groups.
So all of your errors,
if they are the same,
are going to be grouped together
in this place as one group.
So this is out of the box when
you use App Engine, especially
Node.js App Engine.
That is all for the
demo of the resources.
Let's go back to the slides.
And now I'm going to
talk a little bit more
about how to connect
Microservices.
So of course, you can
directly call a service.
So that's the case
for example, when
a client calls our front end.
So an HTP request arrives,
that's a direct call.
It's also the case when
you receive a webhook.
When you receive a webhook,
that would be a direct call.
And lastly, two Microservices
can call each other directly,
of course.
Another kind of communication
between Microservices,
which actually can be quite
convenient and useful,
is what we call asynchronous
execution and events.
So if you remember, every five
minutes [INAUDIBLE] services
was scheduled.
So this is one kind
of scheduled services.
Now you remember any time we
put a file into Cloud Storage,
something happened.
The function was triggered.
So this is another
kind of communication.
We call that reactive services.
So when something
happens, this is
triggered [INAUDIBLE] events.
Another way to do an
asychronous execution
is to actually use a task queue.
So one service will make
you a task into a queue.
And then this queue
will make sure
that this task is executed
by retrying, if needed,
and by dispatching at
the rate that you want.
So task queues can be
quite convenient for
asynchronous task execution.
And lastly, as we
made in our demo,
you can use a publisher
and subscriber
pattern when one
service will publish
a message into a Pub/Sub topic,
and one or many other services
that are subscribed
to that topic,
will receive the message.
And lastly, maybe
this is obvious,
but sharing storage
is also a way
to communicate between services.
You can have two services
sharing the same database.
That is a kind of connection.
In our case, we used Cloud
Datastore and Google Cloud
Storage.
So connecting Microservices,
you can directly call them,
you can use asynchronous
execution and events,
and shared storage.
MYLES BORINS: So
after kind of talking
about all these different
types of services and products,
you may be wondering when
should I use functions?
Or when should I use App Engine?
Or maybe when should
I use a Kubernetes?
These decisions are things
that teams need to make.
So I want to get a little bit
more into functions first.
So we talked about
events and async
and that's a lot of
the programming model
that's used for that.
So you have different
kinds of triggers.
You have Pub/Sub, you
have Google Cloud Storage.
So whenever something ends up
in a bucket, it triggers it.
You can have database
transactions.
One that's really
interesting is logs.
So you can have a
function run every time
you see things in logs.
You can use that to filter
certain kinds of error messages
or automate pager duty or
something fun like that.
Maybe not pager duty.
But you can also use webhooks.
Any sort of HTTP
can go and call in.
One of the things that's
nice with Cloud Functions
is they can be really
single-purpose.
It has a well-defined
programming model
with a really quick way
to get to the data that's
coming in from the event.
One that I really like is
an emailer, for example.
So you may have a whole
bunch of different services
that need to send email.
So if you have one
Cloud Function that
just does all the auth
and all the message
handling to whatever email
service you're running,
you can make a email topic on
Pub/Sub and just publish a to,
a from, a body, and a title,
and an email will just go out.
And let's say you decide to
change your email provider
service.
You just have to change
that one Cloud Function.
And no one else needs
to refactor their code.
As long as you have a defined
API surface between all
your services that
isn't broken, you
could change it to any language
or any service you want to.
So on the other hand,
we have App Engine.
App Engine, for
example, HTTP services
are generally what are exposed.
Now, it's multi-purpose, though.
You could use it for
front end applications.
You can use it to
serve static resources.
It does not have a
defined function wrapper.
So you can just take any Node
application for the most part
that you've already been
running and just launch it.
If you have multiple
different things that
are going, multiple routes
that you're handling,
database queries
templating, you may
find that running
something on App Engine
makes more sense for the use
case than a Cloud Function.
But you can define your
own compute relationship.
Card functions and App Engine
work really great together.
If your team prefers thinking
about things as functions,
run with that.
I know entire websites that
have thousands of page views
and hours and they've written
their entire infrastructure
on functions.
And there's tons
of big note apps
that could just run on an App
Engine and scale as necessary.
You could really break
apart the problem
as it makes sense to your
team as you need to go.
And they both share a
lot of similarities.
They're both going
to scale to zero
when you're not using them.
You're going to pay
for what you use.
And under the hood, they're
using the same sandbox.
They're using the
same auto scaling.
There's no right or wrong.
One of the cool
things about it, too,
is you can start thinking--
it almost becomes
more of a difference
of how you want to
think about your compute
and how you want to
factor your code.
But from an OPS perspective,
they're very similar.
And we also wanted
to announce today
that [INAUDIBLE] is going to
be coming to GCF really soon.
So you're going to be able
to use all of these features
both on Cloud Functions
as well as App Engine.
STEREN GIANNINI:
All right, to recap,
deploying Node.js Microservices,
serverless Microservices.
What have we seen today?
First, breaking up the monolith.
So as you've seen, we've built
an entire product made out
of very, very simple pieces.
Each of these pieces is a
few files, or even one file
for some of them.
Break up the monolith.
Microservice architectures can
help you build rich products
from a de-coupled, small,
scalable, maintainable,
understandable components.
Second, we showed you
a preview of Node.js
on App Engine
standard environment.
This is coming in a few weeks.
And lastly, what
you should remember
is that Google
Cloud Platform has
everything you need to build
serverless Microservices using
Node.js.
And personally, I
can't wait to see
what you will build with
Node.js on App Engine standard
and all of those products.
[APPLAUSE]
MYLES BORINS: Thank you.
Thank you.
So if you enjoyed
the session, you
can go and get your feedback
here through the schedule link.
You can use web or
Android or iOS, just let
us know what you think.
Here are some resources.
You'll find the docs for
the App Engine standard.
You're going to see the
functions and the demo
that we were showing
you today is all there.
And so just a quick round
of applause for everyone
who's watching at home
on the live stream.
[APPLAUSE]
And one more quick
round of applause.
You don't really see it, but
there are some amazing people
at the back of the
house and the back
here who have been working
all day tirelessly.
Just a round of
applause for them.
[APPLAUSE]
And so don't go yet.
STEREN GIANNINI: One more thing.
One more thing.
Look under your seat.
No joking.
Look over there, we have a stand
where you can scan your badge
and we will send you
invites to try tomorrow,
or as soon as we get your
e-mails, Node.js on App Engine
standard environment.
So if you want to give it a
try, scan your badge over there.
Thank you.
MYLES BORINS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]